hey guys you are amazing I know I said
that in the last video but I just got
the numbers back for how much we raised
for Best Friends Animal Society
we raised eighty one thousand three
hundred and twenty eight dollars and
forty cents that's mind-blowing Liebig
considering that most of that live
stream I was eating string cheese and
trying to manage 25 to 30 thousand
people at the same time by myself which
to admit it was not that good of a live
stream it could have been much better
but you guys still were there and
supporting and laughed and I heard so
many great stories from it and when I
went to comic-con I heard so many great
stories from people saying about how the
things that this channel is doing and
the things that this community is doing
is just inspiring them to do good and
I'm so proud of what you guys have done
because this raises our total for the
over two years that we've been doing
this now to three hundred and seventy
thousand four hundred and seventy nine
dollars and fourteen cents raised for
various charities we've done probably
about nine or ten by now and it just
gets better every day and I can't stop
thanking you guys for the support you've
given and I've taken to Twitter and
Facebook to try to let you guys know how
proud I am of you and how much I believe
in you because people may tell you that
you know you're not doing things right
or they want you to be a specific person
and I try to tell you guys who you be
whoever you want to be you know you are
doing great things right now and even if
you can't donate money or even if you
can't donate time to do charity work or
anything to help out in this just being
here and doing small things together in
a group of over two point eight million
people almost three million people it
adds up it adds up incredibly and I
can't thank you enough for doing that
and that's why I am keeping my promise
to do charity livestream every single
month and I'm not going to drop the ball
on that the next one is going to be
August 23rd don't know what charity yet
but we're going to be selling not
t-shirts this time but special markup
are pajama pants hopefully I have an
image
here or else there's a big teddy bear or
something like that I don't know maybe
both maybe they're dancing a little bit
I'm not sure but either way just thank
you guys so much for supporting these
and this time I hope not to be alone
because Wade gave a tentative yes saying
he would fly out here or I would fly him
out here
and I haven't asked Bob yet but
hopefully he will be available but he's
very busy with Law School and all that
stuff so I don't expect that he will be
available but if he is I would love that
both of them here and I would just love
to have someone else like wait here who
can take the burden so you guys don't
have to watch me act like a fool not
that you guys don't enjoy that but
hopefully less of that more actual
comedy and interesting things to talk
about but just thank you guys again for
supporting these causes and even if you
don't even if you're not to the point
where you believe in yourself yet and I
want you to be I want you to be really
bad because I am so proud of what you
guys have done just know that I believe
in you I made a video about this before
I am so amazed and blown away by the
unity of almost three million people all
together in one place all trying to be a
force for good in the world and that is
inspiring so thank you guys so much for
supporting and hopefully Wade will be
there for this next stream it is August
23rd just to recap oh and before I
forget I meant to do this a few vlogs
ago I was in a music video with random
encounters it was a Captain Falcon music
video there'll be a link right here a
little insert video please click on that
if you haven't seen it already I posted
on Facebook and Twitter but I did not
post it here just watch it it is
fantastic they did an amazing job it's
hilarious full song even sing a few
parts in there I have my own mariachi
band I'm going out on a date how about
that it's incredible
go see it and check out other random
encounter stuff because they are amazing
people so just thank you guys so much
for everything that you've done for me
and for the world and for the community
in general you're an inspiration not
only did
but to everyone else on YouTube so thank
you all so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye